hallo ihr lieben ich lass euch gleich ins
video muss ich aber jetzt vorher die big
news erzählen und zwar gibt es meine kiki
scream das ist einmal die harte riffs creme
und die schokohasen ab morgen in allen kaufland
filialen deutschlandweit allerdings nur solange
der vorrat reicht dem ist tatsächlich ein
bisschen schnell sein und um 20 uhr gibt
es noch eine überraschung auf dem kanal das video
müsst euch unbedingt angucken ich bin so gespannt
was ihr dazu sagt und ansonsten wünsche ich
euch jetzt ganz viel spaß für mein rezept
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es endlich ist mir
bombast für alle die es nicht kennen das ist ein
türkisches rezept und ihr fraglich locker seit 34
jahren wann machst du izmir baumasse das ding ist
ihr müsste ich wohl schon das ist so ein rezept
ich kann sich hier mal zeigen das ist ein rezept
darf den ganz dünnen knusprigen teig und in drin
hat sie dann einfach so eine richtig leckere
schokocreme oder auch eine haselnuss creme und
die letzten jahre gemeinde hasel system bietet
seit einem jahr und letzten habe ich mich dagegen
gewehrt weil ihr müsst euch vorstellen beißt so
richtig auf die creme und die muss natürlich
lecker sein so was bietet sich also besseres
ein als das rezept die jetzt zu dem zeitpunkt zu
machen wo ist meine harte nuss meine schokocreme
gibt und findet ihn richtig gut aus und das ding
ist haben sie es gar nicht da hinter der kamera
ist nämlich sarah und den test mache ich am ende
mit hamza borns im lager im shop der haben sie es
nämlich im job oder fahren am ende des videos
machen aber ich zeige ich jetzt erstmal wie
diese so leckeren dinge funktionieren und ich
gern mit inzest macht wir starten jetzt mit dem
fünf minuten takt ist so easy leute ich gehe jetzt
direkt mein mail in die große schüssel natürlich
könnt ihr auch eure küchenmaschine dafür verwenden
aber dadurch dass es so schnell geht und ein
besseres gefühl hat mit den händen mach das jetzt
mit den sauberen fingern da gebe ich ein bisschen
zucker dazu vanille extrakt finde ich einfach
jetzt für den geschmack ganz nett und dann kommt
da noch lauwarmes wasser und neutrales öl mit
rein und dann einfach alles miteinander verkneten
was hat jetzt keine drei minuten gedauert habe
auf der arbeitsfläche noch mal ein bisschen
weiter geknetet und hier jetzt folgendes vor
ist die baumasse ist eigentlich wirklich nur
so dieser helle tiger wir machen jetzt auch
noch einen schoko teig dafür teile ich den
jetzt einmal in der hälfte durch der eine darf
er ruhig hell bleiben das heißt er ist fertig
man sieht auch richtig schön wie vanille
pünktchen so und den einen teil gebe ich
jetzt hier schon mal in die schüssel wenn ich
gleich auch noch mal abdecken und dann darf der
schon mal gehen gehzeit beträgt nur 20 bis 25
minuten da muss einfach nur elastischer werden
um für den schoko teig nehmen wir uns jetzt ganz
einfach kakao und weil der sich also schlechter
rein verarbeitete ist schon wieder trocken also
erst mit liebe ich den das ist ganz wichtig und
dann nehme ich mir noch mal so ein bisschen was
vom öl dazu in die hände und kriege das dann an
ich glaube ich las den teig sogar so dass
hat so ein bisschen diesen effekt entweder
sitzen nach dem backen nicht gut aus oder
das sind richtig richtig gut lasst uns
einfach mal überraschen so zwischendurch
zu experimente auch immer ganz cool jetzt
gebe ich ihm auch noch mal hin die schüssel
so ein bisschen mehr rein und dann nach 20
minuten machen wir weiter das rezept
es übrigens wirklich ein witz rezept
unsere tage konnten jetzt richtig gut entspannen
dadurch werden sie elastisch sie werden nicht
aufgehen mir auch kein keine hefe oder so was
da drinnen daher nicht wundern und jetzt einfach
auf der arbeitsfläche so ein bisschen zu einer
langen wurst raus rollen und dann werden wir sie
zu kleinen kugeln formen so die teiglinge könnt
ihr jetzt schon mal zu kugeln rollen dann habt
ihr gleich einfach so ein glattes und schöneres
ergebnis ist mache ich jetzt gleich auch und die
kleben auch nicht an der arbeitsfläche also wenn
überhaupt nur so ein bisschen aber dadurch dass
wir das fett drin haben ist es eigentlich gar
kein problem er braucht doch kein zusätzliches
mail sondern es werden sie euch noch zu trocken
was ich auch gemacht habe ich habe meine haselnuss
können das wirklich meine füllung sein ich
nehme meine reiner haase muslim und meine
haselnuss schokocreme nicht zum befüllen und
die habe ich eine stunde zuvor den kühlschrank
getan wenn ihr sie auf zimmertemperatur lagert
was wir eigentlich immer machen sollte ist sie
so wie es auf der verpackung steht unendlich
creme ich hab das sieht man ja auch ganz gut
und wenn ihr den kühlschrank gibt ist einfacher
für uns zum verarbeiten denn dann wird sie so ein
bisschen fest da so wie man hier sehen kann und
so brauchen wir sie können natürlich auch anders
darum machen aber so vereinfacht ihr euch die
ganze sache einfach jetzt werde ich die teiglinge
dünn ausbreiten entweder mit den fingern noch
besser mit seinem aus rolf starb und dann in die
mitte also ungefähr eineinhalb bis maximal zwei
teelöffel von der haselnuss klemm rhein geben
wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr die spitze
noch abschneiden damit den ich so viel
teig untendrunter habt falls ihr das schon
richtig einschätzte müsst ihr auch nichts
von wegschneiden und dadurch dass der teig
vegan es könnte jetzt natürlich auch meine
vegane haselnuss creme nehmen dieses komplett
wega natürlich auch laktosefrei und schmeckt
mindestens genauso lecker wie die die nicht vegan
ist und viele sagen auch man merkt gar nicht dass
der iran ist schmeckt so richtig wie seine milch
creme und davon gebe ich jetzt auch was in oder
auf meinen tag besser gesagt und dann habe ich
natürlich auch die vegane variante und später wenn
ich es sowieso im shop verteilen haben wir auch
einige veganer und die können auch mal probieren
ich packte jetzt immer so ungefähr acht neun
bomben auf einem backblech das habe ich mit
backpapier ausgelegt und es ist ganz ganz wichtig
dass wir den backofen vorheizen versuch richtig
volle power also nehmt euch da wirklich die zeit
für der sollte schön auf temperatur seien 220
grad ober und unterhitze und dann brauchen sie
auf der unteren einschub leiste wirklich nur so
sieben minuten die dürfen auch nicht zu dunkel
werben bei mir zb einer sehr dunkel geworden
das liegt aber daran dass auch der backofen
nicht ganz gleichmäßig buck das werdet ihr auch
haben es ist gar kein problem aber wir sollten
wirklich noch schön hell sein damit der teig
richtig schön knusprig und nicht zu trocken und
innen sollte es dann auch nicht zu heiß werden
und jetzt mache ich weiter mit meinem marmortisch
man sehr gespannt wie der gleich aussehen wird
und das werde ich jetzt auch noch mal einen
teil meine teiglinge wegen übrigens für euch
sollte kleiner hinweis circa 20 gramm damit ihr
euch daran ein bisschen orientieren können und
raus bekommen habe ich gerade 16 teile
und jetzt werde ich wieder 16 einteilen
ich bin jetzt bei mir im shop der haben wir es
dort hinten in der packstation und arbeitet gerade
und ich wollte euch mal zeigen sie mir hier
schön in so eine aufgeschaltete dose gepackt
und jetzt werde ich die bomben noch einmal in
die mikrowelle geben aber auch wenn ich also 15
20 sekunden einfach damit nochmals haben wird
und damit in die creme auch noch mal dass sich
flüssig wird und dann zeige ich euch überraschen
den haben sie damit und zeigt euch dann in testet
hallo mitarbeiter des monat hallo
nicht das machen wir gerne kerne
also ich weiß achim stocker ist ja habe
ich viel geldhauses problem besser warm
ich finde jetzt noch ein
bisschen mehr reiten können
einen geschmack noch mehr weil
ich sage auch die machen richtig du kannst du bis
sechs stück auf einmal in österreich die schlechte
aufnahme leute also leute ehrlich das müsst ihr
unbedingt nachmachen das schmeckt heftig stecker
und alle diejenigen die das mein türkei probiert
haben ich weiß dass zur seite das ist viel kleiner
das